right
is
um
[Music]
yes
good morning everyone it is 10 o'clock
on
what day is today april august 13th it
is a wednesday
um
oh april april see i'm telling you it's
going to be a rough morning um
we are oh this
meeting of the election law committee
has been scheduled today because we have
three early bills early bills need to be
reported out by tomorrow we're going to
try and get what other business we
can uh done
but the reality is we have a couple of
amendments in the works right now on two
of the early bills
so we are really not ready to get going
so we are going to open the meeting and
then recess until 10 30.
um i apologize to everybody for getting
you here at ten o'clock but
um in the effort to get these things
done in accordance with the schedule
that's what happens and
um if you talk to me after the meeting i
can tell you how i can blame it all in
the senate so
um we are going to officially start now
and with that i would like you to stand
and join me in a pledge of allegiance
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america and to the
republic for which it stands one nation
under god indivisible with liberty and
justice for all
thank you very much everyone and we are
madam chair
um can you
um
what are the three early bills sorry i
missed last week's meeting so
let's get going again this is the new
hampshire house election law committee
it is 10 30 we have been in recess we
are here for executive session on bills
all of which have had a public hearing
um there are a couple of things that
were not specifically
in the notice for today's executive
session
one is that we have early bills that
need to be
voted out for the calendar next week
because they will be going
to a second committee they are 366
we also have three bills that we did not
address last week an executive session
that were continued and they are
242 328
before we begin the today's business i'm
going to go through what i understand
people should have in addition to the
actual bill
sb 242 you should have an amendment
1353.
366 there is an amendment coming you
you should have just received an
amendment 1383
1383 is actually
a bill we previously passed in this body
that is under consideration by the
senate
for 18
that amendment number is
1487.
and i believe there is also a fiscal
note
amended
um
where was the fiscal note that wasn't so
pretty
um
there
there was also an amended fiscal note
for 4 18
the one that sort of didn't look like
well we didn't get the the only thing
that looks like a fiscal an amended
fiscal note that we've gotten from them
is 427 so the committee got
what you sent out because you had
mentioned at the last meeting that you
i think
everybody has everything anybody at
their
seat that does not have what they expect
to have or what i just
all right and i want to welcome this
morning we have representative matt
simon sitting in for
uh representative growing who is on a
vacation
um i point that out because
there needs to be some payback for that
by representative simon
representative healey is here for
representative hayward
um
i had a substitute provided to me for
representative hamer
and there she is representative perez is
here sorry i didn't see you
i'm thinking it's representative lane
and that wasn't going to work out um
representative marsh welcome is here for
representative cody
and representative merchant welcome
again
um is here for representative muirhead
and our hope is that when we do roll
all right
um with that i am going to try let's try
to address the bills that we had from
last week if that's all right with the
committee
um so we have sb 242
which is relative to the
disqualification of certain persons from
performing the duties of an election
official
there is an amendment that you have is
there a motion on the amendment
representative terosium
madam chair i make a motion to um accept
amendment uh
2022-13-53-h
is there a second
yes ma'am chairman i second the motion
thank you would you like to speak to
your motion representative teresa sure
thank you
what the amendment does
is it just strikes in lines 13 14 of the
original bill it strikes out the word
for the handling of marked ballots and
it strikes that part out so then it
reads
the in the bold uh lettering other than
a position of an election official shall
not be allowed to remain in the area
designated for the counting of votes
that's how then it now reads if we adopt
all right questions or discussion on the
amendment
representative bergeron
thank you madam chair um
i can't support the amendment uh for all
the reasons that we found house bill
1359 in expedient to legislate
the constitution
dictates orders
mandates whatever words you want to use
under part 2 article 32 that the
moderator shall govern the election at
town meetings and of course
elections where ballots are cast
and we can't pass a state law that
takes away the authority given to our
moderators by the state constitution and
that's exactly what the bill does and
the amendment still does it too
prohibiting the moderator from from
ballots are being counted or handled i
had asked senator gray specifically if
an area could be cordoned off
where
inside the
voting area if an area could be cordoned
off where someone could be assigned to
be processing absentee ballots because
that's something that can be happening
throughout the day and usually does
especially in a big election
but senator gray's response was no it he
really should be out of the building
entirely not just away from that area
so
again i'm going to oppose it because
we're denying the moderator the
opportunity to fulfill the
responsibilities he or she has under the
further discussion
um i'm just going to say i'm going to
i am not
a hundred percent sure that the change
addresses the issue
i think the issue that's being raised by
the election official on
a ballot as a candidate for office is
their actual presence
that their presence can affect
someone's decision to vote for
or against someone
in
the polling place
i don't know
that i've heard anybody say that they
are concerned about the conduct
itself of an official who's on the
ballot however this is an issue that
comes before this committee
session after session after session
and
i think that by restricting it
to the area designated for the counting
of votes
we allow
the moderator constitutionally
assigned to the duties of oversight to
still
conduct oversight duties
i also think it is possible to cordon
off the designated area for counting of
votes
much easier than it is to do
what the original bill proposed which
included
um
the handling of march ballots because
arguably
walking from the voting booth
to the
ballot box is a place where there are
marked ballots so arguably that would
prevent somebody from walking through
that area
and that seemed
not effectively effectuating the purpose
of the bill or practical so
i can't say i disagree with anything
anybody said but
maybe
if we pass this we won't have a bill on
it next year
and we'll see how it works
representative teresa thank you madam
chair
i i do agree with what you said and
again
we know it's not perfect um but the
reason for striking out that verbiage
was to
it basically basically it's a out for
the handling of the mocked ballots the
they can still do that the moderator
even if they're on the ballot so it's
kind of a compromise it it gets us part
way there so for that reason i'm
supporting it but but i concur it's not
perfect
of course all the other bills we do here
in this committee are perfect so there
you go all right any other discussion on
this amendment the motion on the floor
is to amend the bill
seeing no further discussion i'm going
to ask the clerk to call the role on
amendment 1353
yes
no
representative marsh
representative sandler no representative
hamer
representative lane
no it's uh representative perez sorry
no
yes
excuse me
representative lane oh i thought you had
no okay
i heard you speak and that's why i just
knocked it down oh yeah i was just
pointing to
representative perez okay so 11 to 9.
all right the amendment carries eleven
to nine
is there a further motion representative
to rosian thank you madam chair madam
chair i make a motion to ought to pass
as amended for uh senate bill 242. is
there a second yes madam chairman i
second the motion
representative quality seconds it is
there any discussion on the bill as
amended
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
no
representative lane
representative
yes
sb 242 will be
reported as amended with a vote of 11 to
9.
i am asking for committee reports today
to the extent we can get bills in the
calendar
for next week
it means the committee will have less to
do in the last session so we're going to
try to get in what we can though
admittedly everybody's going to be
concentrating on the early bills for the
calendar for next session
um i also want to say i feel a little
bit like the disjointed first grade
teacher where everybody has sat in the
wrong seats i am completely confused by
both sides of the room today
with
representative lane sitting at the wrong
table completely
and i have four individuals at this
table over here so if the chair is
looking around the room
like she's lost something it's because
she can't keep track of where anybody is
today all right sb 328
is a bill that was carried over from
last week
um this is a bill relative to the state
primary this proposes to change the
state primary to
august is there a motion representative
sweeney
madam chair i find we move i move we
find senate bill 328 and expedient to
legislate is there a second
i second that madam chairman
representative barry seconds it is the
would you like to speak to your motion
representative
sweeney thank you madam chair i very
begrudgingly uh moved to find this an
expedient to legislate i
uh eight years ago i sponsored a bill to
move the primary to june uh that got
absolutely nowhere i think it died on
the house floor in a voice vote
last year i sponsored the same
legislation along with some others uh we
passed it in the house uh went over to
the senate it was amended in the senate
to august
we committee a conference it i
begrudgingly agreed in the committee
conference as did others to just try to
get something passed uh with the august
deadline for the senate was not budging
on that
and then that bill to move the primary
to august got vetoed by the governor
and i was really hopeful this year when
i saw that the senate put forward a bill
to move the primary to june that we
would finally be able to get it
a june primary bill to the governor's
desk not speculating what that outcome
would have been but i was hopeful we
would have been able to do that
and unfortunately it seems like we're in
the same place as we were last year with
an august bill
but i don't believe we're going to be
able to
make work this year to pass a june bill
um so i i i believe the supporters of a
june primary uh should not see this uh
more more or less as a setback uh
hopefully next year we can bring forward
a june primary uh that can go the
distance
so unfortunately uh today we're gonna
i'll vote to make this an expedient to
legislate thank you
representative bergeron thank you madam
chair uh i would support the motion to
find this billing expedient to legislate
for the reasons really that the governor
mentioned in his
veto message for a similar bill last
year where he said it could result in
depressed voter engagement in the
election reduced turnout
could hurt the ability of municipalities
to recruit poll work as an election day
volunteers
and i would just add that one of my
election officials in nashua just told
me this week that he didn't believe all
the gymnasiums where we hold our polling
polling locations are necessarily
air-conditioned which means an august
state is not too
too attractive to them so with that i
will be supporting the uh
motion to find this bill in expedient to
legislate representative barry uh yes
i'm a big fan of june i'm not a big fan
of august but i do want to read into
not to belabor this point but i do want
to read a quote
new hampshire hosts the second latest
primary in the nation september 13th
giving the eventual republican nominee
little time and few resources to
communicate after emerging from what is
said to be an extreme and chaotic
primary that is the words of senator
maggie hassan's campaign manager so i
will create a new quote for all of my
friends on the other side of the aisle
new hampshire hosts the second latest
primary in the nation september 13th
giving the eventual democratic nominee
little time and few resources to
communicate after emerging from what is
said to be an extreme and chaotic
primary that is me talking about the
democrat primary for governor today this
cuts both ways we need to fix this it
thank you representative tarosian
thank you thank you madam chair
um
i um
initially was against moving the primary
date at all but
there are many
many good points brought up as to why
september is too late
to
for many reasons i won't go into because
you've heard some of them so um i'll
actually be voting against the itl
motion in favor of the change to august
because i thought it was a good
compromise
further discussion on the motion which
is to itl sb 328
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
yes
representative o'brien yes
simon
yes
representative sandler yes
representative perez
yes
representative lane
no
represent
yes
represent hamburg
uh the vote is 18 to 2. does anybody
have objection to this going on the
see none it will be reported on the
405 is relative to fines and penalties
for election law
violations
[Music]
you should have an amendment
83 3
that should have been
amendment to 405 fn
1383. it's
my name's on the top of the amendment
people have it
representative ward is indicating that
side of the table got it representative
terozian do you have it
all right um
does anybody have a motion on
representative barry
uh
sorry madam chairman yes uh i would like
to move amendment um
uh out to uh through to sb 405. is there
a second i'll second it madam chair
representative bergeron seconds it
um representative barry do you want to
speak um uh we given that representative
bergeron is second and i'm gonna save
some time and move on
um just so people are aware of what 1383
does 1383 deals with the bill this
committee has is a bill this committee
has previously passed in regards to
the conduct of election on a local level
it is an appropriate topic and
consistent with the bill that senator
guida has brought forward
and it is my hope that
the senate will come to grips with doing
something with this issue if it's
presented in the same bill so anybody
else representative bergeron did you
want to speak um
i i think the chair summarized it quite
well this is a bill that passed the
committee although the minority
didn't uh
support it in its original form i'm
referring to the amendment
it was a very minor objection and i
think this
bill is improved with the amendment
that's been proposed and therefore i
will be supporting the amendment and
then the bill is ought to pass as
amended
thank you further discussion on the
motion on the floor which is an
amendment to sb 405 the amendment is
1383. seeing no red lights or hands
representative frida so you're all set
okay i'm going to ask the clerk to call
yes
yes representative lane
yes president freitas
yes
merchant
the amendment passes 20 to zero
um sv 405 is now on the floor as amended
is there a motion
representative barry uh yes madam
chairman i would move that sb 405 be um
ought to pass as amended is there a
second
i'll second the motion represent
representative teresian seconds it is
there any further discussion
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
to call the roll
mcdonald yes
yes
alexander yes
yes represent sandler yes
representative perez
yes representative lane
yes represent freitas
yes represent hamlet yes
yes
um the motion of 405
ought to pass as amended passes 20 to
zero
without objection this will go on the
consent calendar
and that concludes our consideration of
the bills that had originally been
thought to go forward last week
so we are now back to the bills that
have been noticed in the calendar for
this week um the first one numerically
is 348 relative to political
expenditures and contributions
um this bill was the one that presented
uh what
is alleged by some to be the limits in
statute in chart form
is there a motion on 348 representative
torosian madam chair make a motion to um
for house bill 348
i make a motion of autopass is there a
second second madam chairman
representative mcdonald seconds it is
there any discussion on this motion
representative bergeron
thank you madam
chair the language in the bill is
h bill
house bill 348 limits the contributions
an individual can make to a political
party
but removes any limit on what an
individual can contribute to a political
advocacy organization
it also removes any limit on what a
political advocacy organization can make
to a political party
it's kind of a roundabout way of
removing any limit on what an individual
can contribute to a political party
there's also the issue that was raised
when this table was inserted into the
statute the heading of the section
talks about prohibited contributions yet
in the table there are some
contributions that are described as
unlimited
so you can't really prohibit any amount
over the word unlimited
as being ineligible for being
contributed to a campaign
with that said even though i think it's
the bill had a lot of support in the
senate bipartisan support came out of
committee on a five to zero vote
senator susie proposed a four amendment
which passed
and then the bill passed by a voice vote
it appears that the bill
offers
more
that is that is good than what is bad
and so i'm gonna look the other way in
terms of the sloppy drafting of the uh
of the bill
and i will vote to support uh senate
bill 348.
further discussion on 348 representative
terosian thank you madam chair
when it when this first came before us
it uh
first i was like i don't really see why
we need this but then
looking through
the statue and the way
how difficult was to dredge out the
information i
i
to agree it's not perfect what what bill
is but having that
table the gray table even though it's
not gray
um
in i think we should name it the gray
table
okay
we'll have to have an amendment but in
any way it makes it very clear what the
limits are on on the various uh
categories
and it doesn't the bill doesn't change
any of those numbers it just makes it
clear what they are
for that reason i'll vote yes
further discussion
i i agree with representative bergeron
and i think it was actually um
zinc from open democracy who brought up
the double negative so i pulled out
afterwards and i just did again the
statute and i think this goes to one of
the things i've been saying for a little
while is that our election laws need to
be rewritten because the reality is the
way political contributions are in the
statute is as a negative
so
it makes it
um
awkward i think in the in the reading
though not
discernible as to what its intent is
any further discussion
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
to call the roll the motion on the floor
is otp
yes
yes representative perez
yes representative lane
yes
represents freitas
yes represent hamburg
yes
merchant
the vote on sb 348 is otp 20-0 without
objection
that will go on consent calendar
the next bill that this committee has
before it is sb 365 relative to absentee
ballot outer envelopes it had a public
hearing on april 6. is there a motion
representative mcdonald yes madam
chairman i would like to move in
expedient to legislate on this bill is
there a second
representative terresian
make a motion to say make that second on
the uh
next speeding the legend legislate on
365.
thank you representative mcdonald would
you like to speak to your motion uh yes
i would madam chairman thank you
um there's a number of concerns uh
regarding this proposed legislation uh
we heard extensive testimony the other
day when we had the hearing
concerns about people with visual
challenges visual impairment being able
to
make sure that their vote was going to
be counted
because of the concern about the
affidavit being properly included
so there's some issues that way there's
been
legal issues in the past between the
state and visually challenged people
there's also security issues with any
kind of pre-processing which is what
this is really about
so uh for those reasons madam chairman i
i'm moving expedient to legislate
any further discussion on the motion
representative bergeron thank you madam
chair i'll be opposing um
the motion to find this bill and
expedient to legislate
yes it is uh
partial pre-processing of absentee
ballots but what that really entails
is allowing the clerk to remove the
affidavit envelope
from the mail-in envelope
attach the absentee ballot request form
to that affidavit envelope and under
use the right term i guess
the uh accessible voting program
affidavit to the affidavit envelope as
well
we're not asking the clerks or any other
election officials to have additional
interaction with voters if they realize
there's a problem with it
people that are voting
in office can just hand the affidavit
envelope over the counter to the clerk
not stick it in another envelope it's
not a big cost savings but you're not
going to be using as many outer
envelopes
i i think in a large election this will
be tremendous help to the election
officials at the polls because it will
save them time slitting envelopes and
removing the affidavit envelopes from
the ballot so i will be supporting uh
senate bill 365 is ought to pass but
since the motion is itl i will be
opposing that first
further discussion on the motion on the
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
to call the role
representative
yes
no
representative
yes
the
for 365
carries
11 to 9
the next bill in front of this committee
is 366. this is an early bill and this
is in regards to requiring an audit of
ballots
cast in the 2022 primary and general
elections
um you should have an amendment
in front of you on this bill 1408
is there a motion on the amendment
representative bergeron uh thank you
madam chair i would move to uh
pass amendment number
h
amendment to senate bill 366.
is there a second
second
representative ward seconds
would you like to speak to your motion
on the amendment representative bergeron
yes thank you
um
i had a concern
as a result of the testimony on this
bill during the public hearing
that the secretary of state's office
might only pull one
accuvote
voting device out of a polling place
even if two were used and the testimony
indicated that the election officials
would be instructed to make sure
the ballots that went through each
accuvope machine were separated and not
combined into a single boxes or a group
and let me share a story a story with
you where my concern comes from number
of years ago during a presidential
election in nashua i was concerned that
we didn't have enough um
ballots coming from the secretary of
state so
as allowed under the law at the time we
had our print shop prepare 500 ballots
for each of the nine wards
and those were boxed separately they
couldn't be scanned of course because
they were printed on heavier stock but
other than adding my signature to them
they uh
they looked exactly like
the official ballots and on those boxes
i put in an eight and a half by eleven
paper uh do not open this box use last
these ballots will not scan
we talked about it in training
and darn it five minutes after the polls
open up i had a call from one of the
moderators saying our ballots aren't
scanning
so i asked him to go back and look at
the box that he opened up to use and he
came back all apologetic i'm sorry i
opened up the one i wasn't supposed to
so we might have the best of intentions
of telling our election officials not to
mix the ballots that went through the
tabulator and machine x with the cartons
that are supposed to hold the ballast
machine y
but that's there's no guarantee that's
going to happen we should minimize the
possibility of human error at the
polling places
i think we would have a much more
difficult problem if that occurs and
then the ballots are taken back for an
audit at the secretary of state's office
and we suddenly find that the high speed
scanner has different numbers than the
accu vote machine had on election night
so
my amendment simply says if more than
one machine is used in a polling place
all the machines using the polling place
should be part of the audit and that's
the purpose for the amendment
representative sweeney
thank you madam chair i just wanted to
thank the member from nashua for
taking a good bill and adding a great
amendment to it and look forward to
supporting it thank you representative
barry that's exactly what i was going to
say it was a good faith effort and thank
you
all right any further discussion on the
amendment
i frankly didn't want to get into the
fact that you picked the wrong machine
to audit and the other one needed to be
audited
that was my concern
so
all right
i'm not seeing any further discussion on
it the motion on the floor is to amend
366 by amendment
i'm going to ask the clerk to call the
roll representative mcdonald yes
yes
yes representative alexander yes
yes senator barry
yes simon yes
yes
representative marsh
yes representative ward
yes
represents sandler yes
representative perez yes representative
lane
yes
representative freitas yes
yes representative merchant yes
yes
the amendment passes
um
for 366 is there a motion
further motion on 366 representative
prudhomme o'brien yes i move ought to
pass as amended is there a second i'll
second the motion madam chair
representative teroshi in seconds do you
want to speak to your amendment
i mean your motion sorry yes this is a
good bill
and uh this is something that will
increase voter confidence it's something
that voters want and i look forward to
representative tarzan did you have your
hand up yeah briefly thank you madam
chair and i too um
supporting this bill but the amendment
makes it better thanks to the member
from nashville for bringing that
amendment and i'll be voting yes
any further discussion on the motion on
the floor which is otpa for 366. seeing
none i'm going to ask the clerk to call
the roll
representative mcdonald yes
representative o'brien yes sen sweeney
yes
yes representative alexander yes
representative sandler yes
representative perez
yes
yes representative
representative
yes
366 will be reported ought to pass as
amended with a unanimous vote without
objection that will go on the consent
calendar
the next bill that we have to consider
is
4 18
4 18 is another early bill
this is relative to verification of
voter affidavits
and you should have an amendment
1487.
everybody have it
i don't have any other amendments on 14
18.
all right is there a motion on 1418
representative barry uh yes madam
chairman i would move that we adopted
him in 1487 to sb 418
is there a second i second that
representative sweeney's second set
representative barry would you like to
speak to your motion yes ma'am chairman
i'm gonna let my comments to just the
amendment because i imagine we'll have
lengthy discussion on the underlying
bill
what i did was i took in many of the
considerations that was brought forward
in the testimony to try to make the bill
more appealing
i'm not delusional to think that this
will change the outcome of the
underlying vote should this um pass
through the movement past but i do think
that there were some legitimate concerns
that were brought up that need to be
addressing so i'll kind of go through
them um
there's three main points in this um the
first of which is a move the enactment
date to january 1st of 2023 we shouldn't
be making major election law changes in
a general election year um it's just
foolish um second thing is i'm sure that
there will be a lawsuit not because i
think there's anything legally wrong
with this but because anyone can file a
lawsuit and get an injunction going
so this will give time for any lawsuit
to work its way through
before we're trying to implement it so
that was a good faith effort to not do
anything in an election year
the first major change is in section one
i removed the requirement for anybody
who's already on the rolls that shows up
without an id um
as is common knowledge now you don't
actually need an id to vote in new to
when you're voting in new hampshire they
ask you for your id you don't actually
have to show it i'm not going to change
that the reason being is that we cut off
registration 14 days before an election
it's a job of the supervisor checklist
to make sure the people that are on the
checklist actually live where they say
they live so i'm going to let them do
their job
so this scopes this bill down to just
people that are showing up on election
day with nothing um so now we are only
talking about people who are showing up
to the polling location on election day
with nothing um so i think that is that
is that is the problem
um the other the other main excuse me
the allergies are getting me um
the other thing i did was i changed down
the i changed it to a seventh day after
the election instead of ten that wasn't
to make it harder um it's just to try to
accommodate some of the iokava concerns
that were brought up but no one's trying
to disenfranchise military voters here
that's that's ridiculous um let's be
real i'm the son of a vietnam veteran my
brother's a veteran no one's trying to
disenfranchise veteran voters here
active duty military voters here it's
it's ludicrous um so we are going to try
to address that somewhat
um and bring that down so that our
military people overseas can get their
ballots on time in compliance with you
acaba
once again it's a good faith effort um
still doesn't make the bill perfect um
there's still some things i would see
like to be changed but it'll send it too
many conference and i'm sure the senate
will opine on this and we'll we'll have
something else that will come forward um
but you know i think it does make it um
it is undoubtable to my friends on the
other side of how this makes it better
i know that you probably still won't
support it but it was a good faith
effort
thank you further comments on the
amendment that's on the floor which is
1487 representative bergeron thank you
madam chair
well i appreciate the movement to
shorten the amount of time
for the purpose of accommodating you
okay for voters
uh i would remind members of this
committee that last year
we had a bill before us
every sixth or seventh year the state
primary election to the first tuesday in
september and the secretary of state
testified at that
point uh during the testimony that the
reason for doing so is at the end of the
recount uh there were only a few days
where the secretary of state's office
could
manage to get the ballots printed to
meet the 45-day requirement under yuo
kava
so while this might make it a little
easier in most years
to meet the requirement to get these
affidavit ballots pulled and sent to the
secretary of state there will still be
some years
where there won't be enough time to get
the general election ballots out 45 days
before the election so for that reason
i'll be uh opposing the amendment as
representative barry just i want to
point out that all this could be avoided
if we had a primary in june i i sort of
had a thought that that might be what
you said but i reckon there you go any
any other
comments
all right seeing none i'm going to call
uh ask the clerk to call the role on the
representative mcdonald yes
representative
no
representative perez
representative lane no represent radius
no represent hamlet no
no
yes
the amendment carries 11 to 9.
it's sb 418 is now before us as amended
is there a motion
representative terezian thank you madam
for ought to pass for senate bill 418
as amended
is there a second
representative quailly seconds it thank
you yes
sorry as soon as i said it i'm like wait
a minute the mic's not on yet
all right
um
representative tarosian would you like
to speak to your motion
so
this is a bill that
certainly um
i can't speak for everybody else but if
they're on the same
email list as i am i've gotten
substantial emails and heard from many
many constituents
as to why
they feel this is a good idea and
and i certainly do as well
and with the amendment
it certainly
addresses some of the concerns that some
people had
in regard to
the military vote nukava
uh the secretary of state himself and
testimony had had brought that up that a
seven-day would would address that for
those that don't know i'm a united
states coast guard veteran
and
i take
the
ability to ensure in
the um
the mechanism to ensure that our
military wherever they may be in the
world can exercise their right
quite frankly if it wasn't for our
military uh through some major conflicts
we we probably still wouldn't have the
right so i very much um appreciate what
they do for us and certainly would not
never vote against something that would
the by amending the bill
we
get a chance to digest
how this is going to work with local
elections prior to a statewide election
to work out any
items that may be some unforeseen
but in regard to what you heard will
there be a lawsuit
sure we we love to have lawsuits um i
would point out this this
is not
senate bill 3.
this is
different than senate bill 3. i
i'm not an attorney but i believe it
would pass muster um we had a
representative who was a co-sponsor of
was in that position of being a judge
and he believes with his knowledge and
having sat on the bench and heard
um
various uh legislative um
items that
he believes
in his opinion it would pass monster we
don't know until it if and when it goes
there but by changing the
date that gives time for any that come
forward to be worked through
regard to
showing an id
let's
let's be honest in 2022
what can't you do without um having an
id you can't buy alcohol you can't cash
your check
i think in some times you can't even
register your dog
um you can't register your boat
and on and on you can't get on an
airplane you can't um you go to a hotel
you have to show an id
we heard testimony that somebody was
picking up their child from daycare and
forgot to bring
their license with them most daycares
you have to show an id to pick up your
child so
anyway
today
we live in a time when
you need an id to function
in society with whatever you do
so
for all those reasons i
will be voting
yes to otter passes amended for senate
further discussion 418 is on the floor
it's amended representative bergeron
thank you madam chair
i'm not sure how to summarize two hours
of testimony in a few minutes
um
and i and i know everybody was very
attentive to the speakers that we heard
last week on this bill but i do want to
highlight a few few points that were
made
again let me start with the problem
about getting those ballots ready 45
days prior to the general election
that's still a concern
the amendment that was passed might have
helped a little bit for
uh most of a seven year cycle but
certainly not all
um
cordell johnson and by mail and others
in person pointed out that there's
already a statute that says no mark of
any nature shall be placed on any ballot
by an election officer and yet here we
are telling them to identify uh
so-called affidavit ballots which by the
way the secretary of state called
provisional ballots
identify them and and keep them separate
and so
i raised the the point uh
about our constitution the recent
amendment says that an individual's
right to live free from government
intrusion in private or personal
information is natural essential and
inherent
this
affidavit so-called affidavit ballot
process
violates the principle of the secret
ballot uh the moderator is identifying
voters putting uh a matching number so
that that ballot can be matched up with
the voter later and uh that voter's
ballot may under certain circumstances
be disallowed
uh
i don't
i don't know where else to go from there
um
let me let me stop there i i think it
i i did raise the point of a court case
that occurred in kansas
where uh the 10th circuit court had
indicated that
requiring documentary documentary proof
of citizenship from certain voters was a
violation of the 14th amendment under
the
equal protection clause i think we have
state and federal issues here
to be concerned about uh
and given that the state spent four
million dollars on litigating senate
bill three i don't think we should be
too casual about
just simply saying well this will
probably end up in court because we're
spending taxpayers dollars when it's
unnecessary
i will be opposing senate bill 418 as
amended thank you
thank you representative sweeney thank
you madam chair i'm going to read from
the amendment that has now replaced the
the section of the bill
for all elections if a voter on election
day is registering to vote for the first
time in new hampshire and does not have
a valid photo identification
establishing such voters identification
or does not meet the identity
requirements of rsa 659-13 then such
voters shall vote by affidavit ballot
pursuant to this section those are the
only voters under this bill as we've
amended that will be voting by affidavit
ballot in new hampshire the goal of new
hampshire should be that nobody
votes by affidavit ballot
everyone should be able and and the
knowledge should be out there that they
are compliant with the law of voting
before they get to the ballot box
this is a a
really we've we've amended the bill and
we've taken the bill sponsored by
senator geida guida
and i believe we've made it
far better
and something that can work for the
state of new hampshire but we need to
stress to all voters and would-be future
voters in new hampshire
if you show up with your photo
identification when you vote when you
register to vote on election day and
again just though for those same day
voters
you will vote by with a with a ballot
just as everyone else if you register to
vote without photo identification
proving you are who you say you are
then this provision of a affidavit
ballot gets into effect i think that's
very important to remember
because everybody should be voting
with proper identification
so that they don't have to file an
affidavit ballot
and i just believe that that is what the
people of new hampshire uh pursuant to
the emails and certainly the phone calls
that i've been receiving
they want us to to have this system it's
really a check and balance to make sure
that every eligible granite state voter
that can vote is able to vote
and that those that are not eligible are
not casting votes in deciding our
elections so i look forward to voting
for this bill
and if it goes to a community conference
i'd be willing to to be one of the few
volunteers to serve on it uh in order to
continue the conversation um and i want
to thank the sponsors who brought it
forward from the senate and i want to
thank representative barry for for his
amendment to it to make it stronger and
i look forward to seeing this go through
thank you further discussion
representative
hamlet
thank you madam chair
um
so the result of this bill would be to
delay the election result
we already do require identification we
require an id to register
or to vote
if a person forgets his or her id they
have to sign an affidavit already
the secretary of state follows up on the
affidavits after the election
and the bottom line is that there is no
substantial voter fraud happening in new
hampshire so there is no reason for this
bill
thank you
representative barry um yes i'll try to
be brief um but like representative
bergeron said it's hard to
put such a big bill in two hours and and
to be real fast um the first is that
voter id is overwhelmingly popular
i believe a poll from saint anselm
showed that 50 of democrats in new
hampshire support voter id overall with
the electorate it's like plus in the 77
percent three-fourths of voters support
showing an id to vote i mean come on
like it's it's as representative uh
trojan said it's 2022. you can't buy
cold medicine without an id
um the the second the second thing is is
uh
this is about the nvra and i i really
wish new hampshire would seriously look
at the nvra
i'm not for federalizing our elections i
was three when they passed the national
voter registration act so it's kind of
uh predates me a little bit if you will
but there's things in there that would
solve basically all of these problems
and you know we keep trying to do these
workarounds and i may be an unpopular
opinion and maybe i'll get attacked by
both the left and the right for this but
we should look at it we should actually
have a good faith conversation about it
um i want to address two concerns um the
first of which is representing the other
side uh the delay it's worth the delay
if you know you're getting the right
results so um we currently have a system
where and respectfully
to the representative an affidavit is
not an id if you have somebody who's
committed to double voting signing a
piece of paper where you're giving them
a fake name and a fake address is it's
not a it's not an adherence it's it's a
piece of paper i think it's all it is
it's it's it has legal authority hard to
track down somebody when you don't know
who they are where they live what their
name is how to contact them um
so we don't have a system of ids in new
hampshire we ask for one we do not
actually require it and an affidavit is
a joke um in terms of and um the other
side didn't bring this up in the
testimony today but it was brought up in
the hearing
about the secret ballot
and that by how by removing these
ballots you'll be revealing how somebody
voted uh the fact is is that they
shouldn't have been voting they didn't
meet the qualifications to cast a ballot
so you're taking out a ballot that
should not have been in there so this
notion that the secret ballot has been
removed it should have never been in
there to begin with they didn't meet the
qualifications so this is an attempt to
to tighten up new hampshire's absolutely
ludicrous same-day registration system
and let me explain and i'll end with
this just how ludicrous this is
somebody can show up at any polling
location in new hampshire any polling
location there's 12 in manchester
they can walk in
they can register to vote they present
nothing
nothing they
boy scout honor their way into a ballot
they say i am who i say and trust me i'm
not lying to i promise you i'll sign
this piece of paper saying i'm not lying
to you and we hand them a regular ballot
that goes in with every other ballot
most of this state is actually from
other states i think i hear as high as
70 i don't think it is but it's over 50
of the state is born somewhere else
including myself
most other states have some form of
provisional balloting this is not
provisional balloting
but when you tell people in new
hampshire that people who register to
vote on election day that present
nothing absolutely nothing other than a
signature
and they're handed a full ballot they
think you're gaslighting them they think
you're making something up but that is
our current system so we're trying to
address that system i have never said
that voter fraud is rampant in new
hampshire i've never said that i have
said in over the last two years of this
committee hearing that i think that
there is a serious problem with people
having faith in the election and there's
an almost butterfly effect from the fact
that we have a system where anybody can
walk into any polling location present
nothing can be handed a ballot that
helps breed these conspiracy theories
and it's the ultimate form of voter
suppression when people don't have faith
in the ballot they don't go vote
that's the it we're trying to address
that this is a very
you know i don't even know if it's
common sense but it's it's because i
think the nvra would be common sense but
this is a way to address this issue
without doing the nvra i wish we were
doing the nbra but once again we'll go
into that but that's my piece on this so
further discussion representative perez
thank you for uh let me speak on this uh
bill
uh this is very concerning to me
someone who wasn't born here and someone
who had a hard time register to vote i
was sent home three times
before i was able to register do you
imagine someone who wasn't born here who
is a new citizen
who haven't like literally haven't get
the u.s passport because those were the
things that i was required to present
when i was i was
registered to build the first time
do you imagine if the person don't have
the us passport
and they still waiting because the
citizenship paperwork it doesn't get it
gets in the mail too after you you get
your hearing and you swear and
everything
you imagine taking away that from the
border that just literally just had the
citizenship and they have the right to
vote but we're trying to take that away
from that person
and i with all the respect from
representative barry
i i you know i
i have respect for all you you know your
concerns and what you're saying but to
be honest we don't want to disfranchise
more voters
and that sounds to me like we trying to
dis-franchise
new citizens and people of already
having trouble getting registered to
vote
that's my only concern
thank you representative further
discussion representative tarosian thank
you madam chair
just to reiterate what we really the
intent of this legislation is to ensure
that people bring their
their id to the polls
before we pass
and require town clerks to check
their
voters ids
many people including myself sometimes
wouldn't necessarily remember to bring
my wallet because i
leave it at home many times
but once we pass that i made sure i
grabbed at least my my driver's license
out of my wallet so i had it i think if
if this becomes law people will
it will reinforce
that
to not forget to bring your id with you
when you go to the polls
and
it's that simple in regard to
lawsuit that we talked about earlier i'm
not advocating i'm not looking at it
cavalierly that um
there should be one because i believe
this
bill as amended
should pass scrutiny um i'm just saying
the reality is that more than likely
somebody will which is unfortunate but
um those are the
the realities of the way we are in
society today and that's the re one
another one of the reasons for the
amendment it helps us address that if if
somebody does bring one i hope somebody
doesn't because i think it's it's a good
further discussion representative ward
oh thank you madam chair i i do think
the amendment makes a uh a bad bill much
better
uh and but in addition to the sort of
philosophical disagreements one might
have with a bill like this it has a
number of practical issues that
probably don't need to go into in
in great detail but it it confuses the
the role of ward moderators with town
moderators it sets up a
process for election officials that's
cumbersome to the point of being
preposterous
um
and it really is a
provisional ballot bill i think the
distinction they're trying to make is a
distinction without a difference
so for
both those practical and philosophical
reasons i can't vote for this bill
thank you
representative lane
thank you madam chair um i want to echo
what representative ward just said that
this is a provisional ballot it is the
distinction that is made is one that
really is not a difference
um
to address another point the affidavit
is not a joke it subjects someone to a
fine of up to five thousand dollars so
we have teeth in our existing law to
enforce what is already in place
also to point out not everyone has a
driver's license and i think
representative
perez addressed that issue not everyone
can get a driver's license particularly
if you are a new citizen or you don't
know how to drive
there are a lot of elderly folks include
who do not have a driver's license
or the one they have is expired
so there are a lot of issues so if we're
going to require driver's license as the
only method we need to be careful
because there's other ways of providing
photo identification
um i also wanted and i missed the
hearing
so
does this jeopardize our exception to
the motor voter requirements
that in that bill i i honestly don't
know
that's the question i don't know if it
i'm
i'm i'm sorry representative lane i've
got a procedural issue that just came to
my attention okay well my question was i
missed the hearing
um last week so mike did someone address
that this may jeopardize our exception
to the motor voter requirement and i
think that's the bill that represented
barry may have been referring to
i i don't think so but representative
barry uh yes i believe the brennan
center for justice actually did address
that um i ironically i believe their uh
their representative did that as an
attempt to dissuade me from supporting
this
not realizing that i would love the if
the nvra was kicked in um to another
point we said about just a driver's
license i think it's uh 659 13 outlines
all the forms of id that we take
up to and including like a college id
from dartmouth
um
so i i unless you were just making a
reference about expired licenses then i
apologize by putting words in your mouth
um i wouldn't wouldn't want to do that
but i just want to address that point
representative bergeron thank you madam
chair
uh and i would like to expand upon the
uh
the testimony from the speaker from the
brennan center center relative to the
national voter registration act also
called motor voter
um
some of the points made is that
the motor voter laws
says that all voters
the exemptions require that all voters
in the state be able to register on
election day
they must be
able to register at the polling place
and such registration must be at the
time of voting in the federal general
election so there is a real there were
other reasons given but there is a real
possibility that enactment of this bill
might remove new hampshire's exemption
from the national voter registration act
and i believe and and i can stand to be
corrected that the
secretary of state's estimate of the
cost to implement motor voter was about
representative barry
just like quit uh
ripping brother do you have to answer
this question if you don't want to um
but it
could we in theory pass a and
tangentially really do this queen theory
pass a a law that banned same-day
registration for people casting a state
ballot where they could only get a
federal ballot would that be in your
opinion in line with the nvra
further discussion on this
um i i will say that uh you may have
recalled during the the meeting i i
asked just
for me
uh that i asked to speak to the person
from the brennan center and we went
outside
because i wanted to
i asked her for the exemption that we
have to the nbra
because it's been something i've been on
this search for for a while
and she didn't have it she went back to
an old memo that she had so we talk
about triggering all sorts of things and
i think they're they're grossly
premature
um in regards to the voter id this is
beginning to sound a little bit like the
arguments that occurred in this body
before i was a member of it in regards
to the institution of the requirement of
voter id to the extent we have it
because there was much discussion and
objection to it that it was going to
cause all sorts of problems
um and the reality is it sort of was
enacted with basically a whimper
and i do want to just provide
information for the committee and people
who might be listening
we're doing a lot of talking about
affidavits and possibly changing things
and what this will mean what we're
talking about is something where we have
a count on election night and it might
change in seven days
this is still far ahead of pretty much
every other state in the united states
in regards to when they have their
official voting results
um so the question becomes if we don't
have substantial fraud and i would
posit that that's not what is necessary
for the state to have an interest in
ensuring that all ballots are cast by
qualified voters
what exactly would the impact of this be
because we also heard testimony from a
representative who lost a race by a vote
so
what is the potential in a primary that
we are actually going to
result in a change in the winner because
that's what we're talking about the
issue of printing a ballot after a
primary for someone to vote on because
otherwise there really isn't an issue
and in 2020 um with information provided
by the secretary of state's office
domicile affidavits not no longer a part
of this bill with the amendment there
were a total of 2859
completed throughout the state
186 were returned as undeliverable
a
141 of those were resolved by the
secretary of state's office before
referral for investigation and 45 are
currently in investigation
qualified voter affidavits
there were 652
completed qualified voter affidavits in
2020.
32 people returned their postcards that
even that's even pretty dismal for a
survey when you put it out and you're
hoping for a response rate
290 s
never simply never came back
no they got sent somewhere put into
somewhere and never got returned and 40
were actually returned as undeliverable
and challenge voter affidavits which is
the no id
there were a total of 733
completed throughout the state
of those
438 returned the follow-up card
215 did not respond in other words those
cards did not come back they ended up
somewhere no one returned them and 45
were returned as undeliverable
i believe we heard testimony in another
hearing from people who were following
up and finding out that a lot of these
cards were sent to homes where new
owners were saying yeah we get mail for
this person all the time they're not
here it goes in the trash
and we also heard testimony about the
one person one vote but so what we're
talking about potentially
um for
733 if we take 2020 which was an
extraordinary turnout
438 return the card so that means we are
talking about that number of people and
45 returned as undeliverable i would
posit that that might be the people that
people are worried were somehow
disenfranchising by not voting meeting
requirements it's not disenfranchising
um so just so you have those numbers for
your records i thought that would be
helpful
um the motion on the floor
is ought to pass as amended for 418 is
there any further discussion on it
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
to call the role
representative mcdonald yes
representative
o'brien yes representative sweeney yes
representative healey yes representative
alexander yes representative
yes
representative barry yes representative
simon yes representative
yes
clerk is yes
representative bergeron no
representative marsh no
representative ward no
representative sandler
representative perez no representative
lane no
representative fragis no representative
hamlet
no representative merchant no
madam chair
yes okay 11 to 9.
sb
18 will be be reported as ought to pass
the next bill to be considered by the
committee today is 425 relative to the
establishment of an election information
portal
um we had the public hearing on this
last week on april
8th
is there a motion on 425
representative barry uh yes madam
chairman i move that sb 425 be
inexpedient to legislate
is there a second representative sweeney
i second that motion but i'm sure
representative would you like to speak
to your motion i'll be brief because uh
we're we can make it to lunch for once
which will be exciting for election law
um
um sb425 establishes the uh i think we
saw a similar bill last year about the
online portal um
it has a it has a price a price tag of
11.5 million dollars
which is pretty incredible we just
talked about the nvra would only cost us
six million dollars not that i'm pushing
the nbra today um
but um 11.5 million dollars i look at
that into kind of things that we've
passed this year that caused um you know
heart attacks efas letting you know
disadvantaged and working class families
have access to different schools is 8.4
million and we lost our mind over that
um so 11.5 million dollars for basically
a website and a database that probably
programmed in sql with some python
background um
would uh is a little a little absorbent
so um
it's in attacking in things that um
would be in the nvra making you should
register to vote that sort of stuff but
it comes with none of the integrity
measures so until we get serious about
this stuff i'm going to be voting no and
i'm not going to be putting an 11.5
representative bergeron thank you madam
chair
i will be opposing the motion to find
this legislation and expedient to
legislate
um
well i
appreciate the reference to the
financial note here saying that it's
going to cost 10 000
over a period of uh three fiscal years
uh to implement this system i find that
really hard to believe sometimes if you
look into the details of how those
numbers are arrived at
the department of information technology
for example is saying that maintenance
and operations will need to be increased
to four full-time equivalents
and i'm sorry we've seen a lot of bills
come before this committee where uh some
of the departments say well i'm going to
need
an additional full-time person in each
of the substations of the
motor vehicle division to implement this
provision
and sometimes it's just an opportunity
and this assumes the fiscal new note
assumes that the software and licenses
are all going to be developed in-house
that's not what the bill says actually
the bill says that this
idea or
suggestion for voter information portal
will be developed in consultation with
the department of information technology
i would also point out that the
secretary of state's office currently is
is going through an rfp process to try
and
establish a new voter uh registration
system
the the current one is is antiquated it
can't be used with uh some of the more
modern browsers uh
particularly in terms of microsoft um
and it's it's it's breaking apart we had
testimony during one of our hearings on
a different bill this this session for
example that if you wanted to have an
updated absentee voter request list
you might be able to get it in a few
months because the software is breaking
down so much so to me it makes perfect
sense that
the work
that will need to be done
to help develop or design
an election information portal
should probably be done simultaneously
with the development of new voter
registration software and therefore i
will be supporting the bill because one
i don't believe the fiscal note and two
uh i think in terms of efficiency this
is the time to do it
representative sweeney thank you madam
chair uh very briefly um i'll be
supporting the motion of any speeding to
legislate but knowing how sometimes
policy that switches from one body to
the other somehow finds a way back uh in
later april and may i do want to just
note for the record that i also have
concerns not only with the fiscal note
of the bill but during the testimony
there was reference to consumer data
being commingled into this online
election portal
tying individuals financial histories
and their purchases and even my even
having card uh even either debit or
credit card information stored on that
file i am very uh uneasy with the idea
of the state getting into that sort of
data collection process of voters or
residents or whatnot
so if somehow this policy or this bill
finds its way back uh either this
session in another vehicle or or in the
future
i think that's a real concern that
members of this committee or any
committee that it goes to
needs to protect the the individual's
privacy and the data
that is being collected and that was
just one thing from the testimony that
alarmed me and wanted to put that on the
record so we were all aware of it thank
you
representative bergeron thank you madam
chair uh just a quick follow-up to those
comments the uh
maybe that's why the
dollar amount of the estimate for this
kind of program is so high because
there's no need for the state to develop
a
credit
credit based authentication or knowledge
based authentication system
those are already exist and i would be
willing to bet a lot of you have already
used these for different purposes where
you're trying to access information or a
record or make corrections to uh to a
credit card
database
suddenly five or six
screens will pop up and we'll say choose
one of the following addresses where you
previously lived at or you have lived at
the current residence for x number of
years and they're all multiple choice
questions that's information that's
gathered by third party software it
scours credit bureau reports it scours
public records and then throws up a
series of questions for the person to uh
to answer it's it's an established
well-used process it's not tied into the
voter registration system or the example
i gave during
the hearing to our vital records system
it resides outside of all that so um i
thought it was an interesting suggestion
but again we're talking about forming a
study committee and perhaps the study
committee will say well we don't even
want to use that there's other systems
out there that would be cheaper and
easier for our public so
um that's what that's what a study
committee is for and and with that i
will end my comments
i thank you representative bergeron if i
can say in response i don't understand
this to be the formation of a study
committee
which is why i'm going to be voting
against it um i think i expressed
concern in the hearing about the
composition of who's going to be in
consultation for doing this and not that
i don't think that we have wonderful
staff throughout the state but the idea
of sort of giving what appeared to me to
be pretty
um
the group identified without any sort of
outside
oversight
for the expenditure of 10 million
dollars did not seem appropriate to me
and again we may or may not agree that
10 million dollars but what we also
heard was doit
is is thinking about this as the basis
for doing other things for other
departments and i think what i heard was
and that cost is going to come down as
they're doing other work for other
departments almost like we're taking the
10 million dollars and spreading it
around
even though it's still 10 million 10
million dollars if it was the study
committee i i probably would have been
more in favor of it but it basically
says
you you go out and do it but don't have
it usable before january 1st of 2023.
um
i
thought about doing an amendment for a
study committee for this i frankly
didn't couldn't get to it
i frankly would have been more in favor
of a budget for allocation of hiring a
vendor to make recommendations for the
implementation of an information portal
that addresses this and then if there
are other departments that wanted to get
on it to do that i think representative
bergeron pointed out in the hearing that
there appears to be subscription
services being used now in our town and
cities that may or may not have been
accounted for in connection with putting
this bill together um so i think there
were a number of reasons during that the
committee hearing that led me to believe
that this was not ready to go forward
so i will be supporting the motion to
itl
representative barry
just one final point about government
contracts
people who contract with the government
have an amazing ability to bring things
in right at the maximum quote
so if you tell them they got 11.5
any further discussion
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
to call the rule for the vote
representative mcdonald yes
representative o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative healey yes representative
alexander yes representative
yes represent barry yes represent simon
yes representative
yes marcus yes
representative bergeron no
representative marsh no
representative ward no
representative sandler no
representative perez no
representative lane no reps and freitas
no representative hamlet no
representative merchant no madam chair
yes
11-9
sb 425 will be reported out of committee
as itl with a vote of 11 to 9.
remains before us to be addressed this
is modifying the absentee voter
registration process absentee ballot
application
an absentee ballot voting process this
had a public hearing
on april 6. is there a motion
yes madam chairman representative
mcdonald i move that
senate bill 427 fn be
uh determined to be in expedient to
legislate
is there a second i second the motion
representative
second set uh representative mcdonald
would you like to speak to your motion
uh yes very briefly madam chairman
uh the provisions the modifications this
bill proposes
are very vague uh very open-ended and
frankly the current
allowances for absentee ballot uh
absentee participation are sufficient
and this bill is unnecessary
further discussion on the motion
representative bergeron
thank you madam chair
um this bill passed the senate on a
voice vote had bipartisan support
it adds
to the reasons for require requesting
absentee ballot the words illness or
other medical condition
and there are illnesses or other medical
conditions as a sponsor noted
during a testimony that don't fall
within the category of physical
disability
um i can think of an example where a
family member had
prostate surgery a couple of days before
the election and was in no condition to
no medical condition to go to the
polling place he had to
get an absentee ballot uh
he lives in another state brought to him
by a family member
if someone has the measles that's not
necessarily a physical disability but i
don't think the the voters should be
going to the polling place and i think
everybody at the polling place would
rather that person stay home too
so there are reasons legitimate reasons
when people may be ill or have other
medical conditions uh where they are
they should be entitled to vote absentee
and therefore i will be
opposing the motion to find this and
expedient to legislate and will be
supporting the bill if a motion about to
further discussion on the motion
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
to call the roll
representative mcdonald yes
representative prudhomme o'brien yes
now sweeney yes representative healey
yes representative alexander yes
representative
yes
representative barry yes representative
simon yes
representative kweily yes
yes
representative bergeron
no sorry
representative marsh no
representative ward no
representative sandler no
representative perez no
representative lane
no
representative freitas no
perfection hamlet no
representative merchant no
madam chair
yes
11 to 9.
sb 427 will be reported out um
as
in itl 11 to 9.
um you may think that's the end of your
business
um
however
the chair makes a motion
to reconsider
um our last
the sb
405 and would request a second so she
can speak to her motion
representative sweeney speaks
seconds it thank you
um i have in front of me another
amendment 1499
um which was part of what had been
discussed with ols earlier
um in regards to a provision of sb405
as it originally came to us that did not
make it in to the amendment and i'm
going to
i would like the to reopen executive
session on this bill so that this
amendment can be considered
um representative barry just a
procedural question to make sure that
we're on the up and up do we need to
vote on the motion to reconsider yes um
because i i will support that obviously
i just don't want what we do to get
tossed it's it's what comes next that
i'm gonna need some guidance on so yes i
do need a vote on the motion to
reconsider
all right
the clerk is getting her roll call
thing done
sorry i didn't give her any advance
warning
um in the meantime i'm gonna just pass
here
so the the this is a motion to
reconsider
all right ready
okay the clerk's gonna call the roll
thank you
representative mcdonald yes
representative o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative healy yes representative
alexander yes
representative
yes
yes representative simon yes
representative quayley yes
yes
representative bergeron yes
representative marsh yes
representative ward
yes represents sandler
representative perez yep represent lane
yes represent freitas yes represent
hamlet yes representative merchant yes
madam chair yes
okay thank you um so
when the original bill sb 405
um
i had noted a question in paragraph 8a
in regards to the statutory references
and the penalty amount
apparently on the senate side that
question had been raised while they were
deliberating by the ag's office but it
was not addressed by the senate
i received word from the attorney
general's office this monday about we
have this amendment that needs to be
done that and i have not received a
response from the senate side as to
their preference
what you have before you is the attorney
general's recommended change
to this provision
which adds the reference to
66417 which
was needed in the section to begin with
and makes the civil penalty
fine
consistent
with
what the law is
and in other statutes so that is the
purpose of this amendment um obviously
this bill will be amended now that we
are reconsidering this bill i will need
to not what will happen is we need
another vote
on the amendment we already passed which
i would request that you vote for
again
because after reconsidering my
reconsideration i really don't want you
to reconsider it so i want you
um to vote in favor of 1383
and then i am going to request an
affirmative vote on
and staff would then in connection with
the processing of it um create a
consolidated amendment
questions
representative bergeron uh
for the comment if i make yeah sure
um
what the chair is referring to
with this second amendment uh pertains
to page two of the original bill lines
10 through 12 and i had questioned that
as well
i thought maybe it was a typo where it
says rsa 664 colon 14 because that
statute refers to political advertising
which is not mentioned anywhere else in
the in the bill
i thought maybe it was supposed to be
17. so this amendment that's being
brought forward i think clarifies the
the confusion
and uh i i will support the first
amendment we already approved the second
one that's being put before us and then
so yes yes and yes we are going out on a
bang everybody this will be three i'm
hoping we'll see what happens
all right so we're going to need three
votes
one on
and then one as otp
as amended
i know i know i just want to look for my
clerk
i don't know if i have enough forms
okay so this one right now
no no no that's not the form she needs
she needs a roll call sheet what about
these
okay up yeah
okay so we're going to do 14 we'll do 14
all right she's got 14 49 done in front
of her
so let's do i'm gonna do 13.93 the
all right okay so let's um yeah yeah
okay
so
um
the vote right now is on the re we have
already reconsidered
so
we we did vote on the reconsideration
right yes
okay so i move
um amendment 1499 to sb 405.
representative sweeney
seconds yes so we're moving the
amendment
and it's 14
99.
no yeah it's just the amendment is that
we're moving on
okay so if you call the roll on that
representative mcdonald
yes representative tom o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative healey yes representative
alexander yes
yes
yes represent simon yes
ward
yes
represent sandler yes
representative perez
yes
representative lane
yes represent freitas
oh no
merchant yes
madame cheer yes
20 to zero 14.99 passes 20 to zero um i
move
amendment number 1383
for
405 is there a second
i'll second
representative terresian seconds is
there any further discussion any
discussion on this motion thank you for
reconsidering i asked for your
affirmative vote i asked the clerk to
representative mcdonald yes
representative o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes griffin
hayward
uh yeah
sorry yes representative healy
representative alexander yes
representative
yes representative barry yes
representative simon yes representative
yes
represent bergeron yes representative
marsh
yes
represent ward
okay represents sandler
representative
perez yes
represent blaine yes represent freitas
yes represent hamlet yes representative
merchant yes madam chair yes
amendment 1383 passes 20 to 0
imove ought to pass 405 as amended by
1383 and 1499.
second and seconded by representative
teresian is there any further discussion
on the motion
i'm going to ask the clerk to call the
rule
representative mcdonald yes
representative prudhomme o'brien yes
representative sweeney
yeah yes
okay
representative healy
yes
representative alexander
representative
yes representative barry
yes
representative simon yes representative
marcus
yes represent bergeron yes
representative marsh yes represent ward
yes
represent sandler
representative
perez
yes
flame yes representative freitas yes
restaurant hamlet yes represent merchant
yes madam chair yes
20 to 0. so it passes as a minute 20 to
0. that
i believe
concludes our consideration of bills
from the senate not only did we finish
up with three consecutive unanimous
votes
we cleaned up the work of the senate at
the same time so a very successful
ending to the committee here
um i want to thank everybody i do not
know that we will be meeting again
because i think at this point everything
is going to the floor um i will be in
touch in regards to committee of
conferences
that may need to attend as
the senate or this body may decide is
appropriate which may require further
committee meetings so
um i think that's where we're at
representative bergeron
given that you said this might be the
last uh hearing of the committee
um i would like to express uh my and our
appreciation to all the members of the
committee i think we got a lot done this
this
this year and last year we didn't always
agree but i think everybody treated
everybody else respectfully and
courteously and i know i know that i
personally appreciate that very much and
thank you
i think i can say on behalf of the
members on my side of the aisle sort of
thank you very much and i i want to
thank you representative bergeron i
think your experience
and your attention to detail adds a lot
and has made a number of bills better
and certainly the comments on the bills
more pointed
i have to say that when i hear when i
see that either you or representative
lane are doing reports
i roll my eyes and groan
because i know they are going to be
detailed quite effective and include at
so thank you to everybody you've been a
pleasure to have around the table with
me thank you for your indulgence uh with
my conduct of the meetings and
i want committee reports today
today representative barry has already
sent me what i have to rewrite
congratulations
thank you thank you thank you i need to
sit here and figure out where all my
no you can you can leave but to the
extent i'll just tell you if i get
committee reports in that means next
week's session
is going to be probably the last session
as a member of this committee that you
have to pay attention to what's going on
so there you go
you